hey everyone welcome to Simply launch
YouTube channel and in this session we
will learn the reasons why chat GPD and
AI can make your business but before we
begin if you are someone who's
interested in building a career in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elects to switch careers with artificial
intelligence by learning from the
experts then try giving a shot to Simply
learn's postgraduate program and
artificial intelligence and machine
learning from the Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM the link in the
description box below should navigate
you to the home page where you can find
a complete overview of the program being
offered take action upskill and get
ahead having said that if these are the
type of videos you would like to watch
then get subscribed to Simply launch
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon so that you are the first
person to get notified when we host
and with that let's get started
artificial intelligence large language
models and AI chatbots have come a long
way and today we have many AI language
models which are helping us throughout
various domains few examples are
Microsoft's Bank Google's bar open AIS
chart GPT Megatron T5 and many more
today we will be discussing about the
caliber of chat GPD and AI which can
leverage you and help you to build a
perfect business so few of the reasons
that you need to consider are the
decision making capabilities of chat GPT
and AI customer services that you can
offer through chat GPT and AI chat GPT
potential to create a content and its
potential to leverage data analysis and
charge gbts and AI capabilities to
provide sales and marketing for you and
run automation for you we will discuss
each one of these in detail so the first
one is decision making capabilities of
charge GPT in terms of raw processing
speed chat GPT can analyze and generate
text at a rapid base capable of
processing and generating responses much
faster than a human can type or think it
can quickly access and retrieve
information from its pre-trained
knowledge providing intermediate answers
to suggestions therefore chat GPT excels
in processing and generating text at
higher speeds however it cannot be
directly compared to humans in terms of
decision making abilities however it is
proof that it is 90 accurate in addition
making whereas humans tend to be
accurate at a rate of 80 to 85 percent
chat GPT is anyways stronger in terms of
decision making at this case followed by
that moving ahead to the next reason
that is the customer service that charg
and AI can help you with if you compare
a human the customer support
representative read the customer care
compared to human the customer support
representative has to read the
customer's query analyze the problem and
formulate the response this process may
take a few minutes or more depending on
the complexity of the issue and
representatives typing speed right but
when you compare it with chart GPD the
AI powered chatbot like chatgpt quickly
scans and comprehends the customer's
query it generates a response within
milliseconds providing intermediate
assistance as well so chat gbt is
proficient at providing customer
services at a much faster rate and it
can also eliminate you the cost of
hiring training and maintaining an
entire Army of customer services moving
ahead we have content creation if you
are a startup company or a company which
needs content creation for your product
then obviously you might end up hiring
Freelancers or a team of content
creators right but compare to humans
shared GPT is proficient at generating
content and can produce coherent and
contextually relevant text so you can
even save money by using the most
powerful and fully operational AI model
to create more versatile and highly
qualified content for you to avoid
hiring Freelancers and employees now
moving ahead the next reason is using AI
models for business data analysis AI can
assist you in data analysis by
leveraging its computational power and
advanced algorithms to possess and
extract vulnerable insights from large
and complex data sets AI algorithms can
automate data cleaning pattern
recognition and anomaly detection tasks
enabling faster and more accurate
results AI models can also perform
Predictive Analytics identifying Trends
and making forecasts based on historical
data additionally AI can facilitate data
visualization presenting information in
intuitive and interactive formats for
better understanding by automating
repetitive tasks and augmenting human
capabilities AI enhances the proficiency
efficiency accuracy and scalability of
data analysis procedures you can rely on
AI language model to extract transform
and load data and analyze your business
data generate reports draw projections
and make data driven decisions to help
grow your company and this also Awards
you to higher and maintain a huge Army
of data analysts which may produce some
or the other errors in real time right
and next reason is sales and marketing
chat GPD can leverage sales and
marketing efforts in the following ways
customer engagement chargpt can engage
with potential customers and real time
answering their queries providing
product information and guiding them
through sales process it enhances
customer experience by delivering prompt
and personalized responses next is later
generation charge gbt can act as a
virtual assistant collecting and
qualifying leads by interacting through
website visitors it can gather relevant
information access customer needs and
provide initial assistance generating
valuable leads for the sales team 24 7
support shared gpt's ability to operate
Around the Clock allows for continuous
customer support it can address
inquiries or for product recommendations
and resolve issues even outside regular
business hours improving customer
satisfaction and retention now instead
of hiring a team and manually marketing
your product on social media platforms
and spending thousands of dollars to run
paid marketing you can use AI models to
crack the algorithms and Market the
product to your target audience with
that let's proceed to the next reason
that is automating your tasks chat GPT
can automate business procedures in the
following ways the first one being
customer service charge APD can handle
customer inquiries Provide support and
resolve common issues through automatic
chat interactions it reduces need for
human intervention saves time and
enables 24 7 customer support lead
qualifications chat GPT can engage with
potential customers ask qualifying
questions and and gather information to
assess their suitability as leads it
automates the initial stages of lead
qualification enabling sales team to
focus on most promising prospects only
next is data entry and processing chat
GPT can automate data entry tasks by
extracting relevant information from
various sources such as forms emails or
documents it reduces manual effort
improving accuracy and speeds up the
data processing appointment scheduling
charge GPD can integrate with scheduling
systems allowing customers to book
appointments or schedule meetings
automatically
finally workflow automation charge GPD
can integrate with business systems and
automate workflows it can initiate
actions send notifications or trigger
processes based on predefined rules
streamlining operations and improving
efficiency by automating various tasks
and processes chat gbt enhances
productivity reduces operational costs
and frees up human resources for
focusing on higher value activities with
their business so these were the few
important ways and reasons why chart GPT
and AI can help you make your business
with that we have reached the end of
this session but before we end this
video let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers hey I'm
Sharia Jaleel I live in Ontario Canada I
have been I.T sector for the past 20
years I recently took the professional
certificate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
course has changed the way I look at
things and helped me back some amazing
freelance projects I started my career
in 1999 and over the years I have worked
with many companies my last tenor was
with IBM Canada my aim was to restart my
carrier and learn something that would
help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome
quality of interaction within the course
was simply amazing the course faculty
was also very experienced and
knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects also I
am planning to start an AI based startup
with my friend where I feel that the
learning from the course to be very
helpful I am really delighted and happy
free time I try to create meaningful
content on YouTube and I talk about new
technologies and what kind of courses
professionals should be taking along
with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band and with that we have come to
an end of this session on reasons why
chart GPT can make your business if you
have any queries regarding any of the
topics covered in the session please do
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of Expos will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest and also do let us know in the
comment section below if you have more
reasons which makes you believe chat GPT
and AI can help you leverage your
business with that thank you stay safe
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here